so recorded a couple of podcast episodes
now but how do I ensure that I'm
consistently getting my personality
across and being myself on the episodes
[Music]
some quite a few episodes in there and
it's safe to say I'm really really
enjoying it now firstly what a beautiful
beautiful day it's nice to be doing some
vlogging out in the garden which my
garden is it's pretty cool to be fair my
parents done a good job but what I
wanted to make a very quick video about
let me just set this up let's make a
very quick video let's make a quick
video about some of the feedback I got
was trying to be a self a bit more I'll
see your coming across well but a bit
stiff maybe a bit too professional and
I've taken that on board and I'm
probably maybe I've recorded maybe about
10 episodes now and I just wanted to
make a video around how am I now on Sam
having a bit more success with just
being myself on these on these podcast
episodes because it is hard because
you're thinking loads of people gonna
listen to it
what they're gonna think and you have
that sort of thought process or if I
need to make sure I'll come across one
all that sort of stuff so what have I
done to make sure that I'm quite simply
just myself a bit more and I think this
is very simple and I think it's just
basically not worry about what people
think so what I mean by that is not sort
of be too professional or too stiff
because I think that's what people want
people want to listen to an honest
conversation with two honest people and
I think if people buy into that and
people enjoy it and people like it and
great if they don't then then that's
fine so I think it was a mixture of
really sort of just just taking that on
boards and not sort of thinking too much
about how I'm gonna come across and send
certain things just really really
just being comfortable with it and
something else that's really helps with
that as well is just basically getting
to know the person that I'm gonna be
speaking to a bit more so always making
sure that I have a bit of a conversation
with them before we do the podcast
episode get to know them a bit more see
other day was and just make it a bit
more of a nice honest open conversation
and yeah I think just just also to have
a bit of fun with it so I am enjoying it
and I think that hopefully as I record
more and more podcast episodes people
will start to think ok right this is
what is like or whatever and hopefully
people buy into that but if they don't
that's cool with me and yes I wanted to
make a very quick video about how can
you just just be yourself a bit more on
these podcast episodes or just be a bit
more comfortable with it and that's sort
of my fault process and how I've dealt
with it over the past couple of months
[Music]